British lawmakers have voted to postpone
a vote on the terms of the UK's
departure from the European Union in a
dramatic Saturday sitting of parliament
Prime Minister Boris Johnson failed to
secure enough backing to hold a vote on
the brexit deal he negotiated in
Brussels just days ago lawmakers agreed
by 322 to 306 to withhold their approval
a defiant Johnson says he will still try
to meet his deadline at the end of this
month to discuss today's historic vote I
am joined in the studio by DW that
brexit brexit an analyst Rob Mudge I'm
also joined by in London by our
correspondent Charlotte Potts and we
have DW correspondent Bernt Riga in
Brussels Charlotte I'll start with you
tell us what is happening where you are
what are reactions to this vote well
outside here of Parliament of the houses
of parliament the atmosphere is really
really heated there and some major
protests going on in London today those
are unrelated to what happened in the
House of Commons today people asking for
a second referendum for a people's vote
and some of the protesters I just saw
pursuing heckling Conservative MPs that
left Parliament after that vote so very
heated atmosphere outside of the houses
of parliament and inside of course a
major blow to Boris Johnson who was
hoping to have a very decisive vote
today on the brexit deal that he has
negotiated with the European Union that
of course never happened because this
amendment passed that now makes him ask
for yet another extension to the brexit
deadline and he will have to do so by
11:00 p.m. tonight yes well as you say a
big blow to Prime Minister Boris Johnson
who was hoping to have this deal voted
on and hopefully approved today
Johnson was defiant though in his speech
to Parliament this is
what he had to say I will not negotiate
a delay with the ego
[Applause]
and neither does the law compel me to do
so I will tell our friends and
colleagues in the EU exactly what I have
told everyone in the last 88 days that
I've served as Prime Minister but
further delay would be bad for this
country
[Applause]
for democracy so Rob a very defiant and
determined Boris Johnson there what does
this mean I mean can he simply ignore
these laws and just push on what I've
been trying to get my head around ever
since I heard the statements it seems to
be that his assessment or understanding
or interpretation of the law is
different from many others there have
been reports I've just been reading that
apparently government lawyers are
already trying to assess what legal
loopholes there are for him to avoid an
extension apparently one of them could
be that Johnson simply refuses to attend
the next EU summit where they would
maybe debate and decide on the extension
another point is that he will refuse to
appoint an EU commissioner leaving that
position empty and one other point that
I've just discovered is that so they may
veto the EU budget which is also now
being discussed so apparently the whole
legal ramifications the process is
already the whole machine is up and
running but I'm really still I don't
know trying to work out what his
interpretation of the law is how it
could differ from what other experts
seem to be is pretty clear that he is
bound by the bent act to go and seek the
extension what sounds like they're still
trying to work out what their
determination of it always as well but
what does this mean for the EU will they
consider another extension Eve you know
as is expected he will he will have to
ask for well the letterbox
in Brussels is open and every
application that arrives here will of
course be considered by the European
Union they require to do that by the law
actually but the EU would be somewhat
reluctant to grant yet another extension
and the president of the EU Commission
jean-claude Juncker said that already
two days ago he was reluctant to even
speak about a prolongation let's listen
in
and I was ruling out that there will be
any kind of prolongation if we have a
deal you have a deal and there is no
need for prolongation that's not a which
is food that's my beautiful
so EU Commission president just getting
very tongue-tied excuse me they're
saying an extension from the EU is not
on the table
Brussels clearly tired of the
back-and-forth burn but others in
Brussels have indicated something else
can you tell us a bit about that mr.
Yoka said it's not on the table if there
is a deal as but as of now there is no
deal because House of Commons did not
agree on the deal so in the end the you
would of course grant takes this
extension because the you doesn't want
to be blamed for letting Britain crash
out on the 31st without any deal so
there will be some negotiations also
maybe some some opposition from France
which was reluctant in the last time in
April banned prolongation was done but
in the end they will do it and the
spokesperson of mr. youngja just said it
is now up to the British to explain what
the next steps will be the ball is still
in the court of Boris Johnson definitely
at this stage now Rob more political
tennis here more back and forth it's
been three and a half years since the
original brexit vote two extensions
later you know all the millions of Brits
left hanging kind of yet again waiting
wondering how is this going to go down
in history momentous I mean you know
regardless of what happens now the whole
process these three and a half years
have just been one long road of twists
and turns and have I think damaged
society they created a rift within the
electorate it's damage to the UK's
psyche I think it will take them
regardless of where we go from here I
think it will take the UK
to recover and it has unfortunately you
have to say become somewhat of a
laughingstock I think in the world yes
certainly yeah very interesting times
but Charlotte I'll turn to you now if I
can because meanwhile thousands have
taken to the streets in London to call
for a second referendum you mentioned it
before but how how are they reacting to
this development have you been speaking
to anybody out there as this does this
outcome boost their cause let me first
just say because we've just learned
about it that the government wants to
grow a goat back to Parliament on Monday
and table this deal that Jones
negotiated with the European Union once
again so that will happen on Monday the
government has just confirmed that and
then in the hopes of course at
Parliament will vote in favor of it the
people here in the streets
tens of thousands today that gathered in
central London their core issue was that
they want a second referendum they want
a vote on whether to approve Boris
Johnson steel and leave the European
Union or whether to remain in the
European Union and just forget about
what happened in the past three and a
half years after that record referendum
so the news here that there will be an
extension that Boris Johnson has to ask
for one that is fitting he's been forced
to ask for one goes down well with them
they say that they appreciated it gives
them more time to fight for their cause
to maybe convince parliamentarians to in
the end support a second referendum a
so-called people's vote but also very
heated atmosphere here around Parliament
we have to say of course most of the
protesters are peaceful but a lot of
them
just gathering around Parliament here
shouting at conservative MPs who were
coming out of Parliament so really this
this day-to-day as rob collet momentous
it really mirrors with those protesters
out here as well well still lots of
uncertainty Charlotte pots in London but
Regan in Brussels and Rob here with me
in the studio thanks very much for your
analysis